-It's so good to see you.
We've had so many fun things
throughout the years,
but to see you in person,
this means a lot.
So thanks for coming to
New York and coming on the show.
We love it.
The audience loves it.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a lot --
We have a lot to discuss.
-Okay.
-Very excited for you because --
congratulations --
you just got engaged.
-Thank you.
-That's a good deal.
-I'm happy for you, bud.
I met your beautiful fiancée
backstage.
-Yeah.
-And you were telling me that --
When you introduced me,
you said,
"This is -- This is Taylor."
-This is Taylor.
-Yeah.
I'm so narcissistic
that I wanted to marry somebody
so I could just call them
Taylor Lautner.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, her name is Taylor.
-Yeah.
It gets -- It gets confusing.
I can only imagine
once we're married
and we have the same both names.
But, yeah, we try --
Her family and friends
call her "Tay," me "Taylor."
Or they literally just call us
"girl Tay," "boy Tay."
-Oh, my God.
I have a photo of you
capturing your proposal.
You're a romantic, buddy.
You are a romantic guy.
Look at this.
Get ready to swoon over this.
[ Audience aws ]
Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah, I mean,
it's right in our kitchen.
Like, the fireplace
is right next to our kitchen.
And this is what I love
about my fiancée
is she's like,
"I don't want anything special.
Like, I just, like, one night
when we're having dinner."
I love to cook.
She's like, "After you cook,
we're having a glass of wine,
just do it in the kitchen.
Like, super simple."
So, I did it in the kitchen,
but I did it, like,
big in the kitchen.
-I mean, candles everywhere,
rose petals.
-I added a thing or two.
-A thing or two.
Oh, my gosh, that's
the most romantic thing ever.
And you got on one knee.
I mean,
she must have freaked out
when she walked in the kitchen.
-She did.
And she's not really a crier,
but she was weeping so hard,
she couldn't even walk.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And I was on my mark, you know,
because I wanted
the photos and stuff.
And I was like,
"Do I have to get off my mark?"
-Yeah, exactly --
"You got to come closer to me."
-She would take two steps and,
like, crumble to the ground.
So I was like, "Crap,
I got to step off the mark."
And I went and I grabbed her.
And I grabbed her hands.
I was like, "Babe,
I have a couple things
I need to say to you.
Like, you think you can
come over here with me?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Because I got this thing
planned out.
There's like 300 candles here."
I mean, "Yeah,
and I got things I worked on."
-We only can do this once.
-Once, exactly.
Have you guys started
planning the wedding yet?
-We haven't.
We're just, like, so excited
about this stage.
We're just, like,
soaking it all in.
-Just in love.
When you guys see them,
just you can feel it.
How did you guys meet?
-My sister introduced us, yeah.
My little sister.
It's just me and her.
She's five or six years
younger than me.
And she met Tay,
and she called me immediately
and said, "I just met
your future wife.
You need to meet her."
So she was like, "You need
to plan a game night."
I throw a lot of game nights
at the house.
-Whoo!
-Whoo! All my game-night people.
-Yes. Yeah.
Big following.
The game-night gang.
Yeah, of course.
-Game-night people
are good people.
-Of course they are, yeah.
-And she was like, "Invite me
and, you know,
a few of my friends,
Tay will just be one of them.
It'll be organic."
And we did that,
and the rest is history.
-You know when my sister met
my wife now of 14 years, Nancy,
she was a producer
on this movie I did.
And she was there,
and my sister goes,
"Oh, you're going to marry her."
And I go,
"No, she's my producer.
Like, what's going on?"
-She's your producer.
Yeah, like, why?
She's like, "No, I can feel it."
-Wow.
-And I was like --
So sisters can call it.
-Sisters know best.
-Yeah, sisters know best.
Congratulations, buddy.
-Thank you.
-I want to talk about
"Home Team."
It's based on the true story
about New Orleans Saints coach
Sean Payton.
And you're actually friends --
you're friends with
Sean Payton, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-How did you get to know him?
-I met Sean when I was --
I was actually filming the last
two "Twilight" movies in --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was filming them --
-You had to know that was
going to get applause.
I was ready to clap.
Once you said it,
I was like, "Yeah!
He said 'Twilight.'
He said 'Twilight.'"
[ Laughs ]
He said it. He said it.
Oh, my God.
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I won't say it again.
-No, of course.
No, no problem.
Say whatever you want.
-I was filming them
in Baton Rouge,
and Sean got ahold of me
and invited me to a home game.
And I was like, "What?"
And I show up to the stadium,
and he's literally there
to open my car door.
And he's like,
"Nice to meet you, Taylor.
I'm Sean Payton."
I'm like, "I know."
And I'm also
looking at my watch.
And I'm like, "I mean, like,
the game starts in an hour.
Like, don't you have
better things to be doing?"
He's like, "You want me to
give you a tour of the stadium?
Like, what do you want to see,
the locker room?"
-I heard he's just the best.
-He's the coolest dude ever.
So he literally
gave me my own headphones,
put me on the sideline
for the game.
He was like,
"Don't press this button
or you'll be talking
to Drew Brees."
I was like, "Okay, I promise."
-Oh, my gosh.
That's wild.
-And that started
our friendship.
And then cut to like five,
six years later,
I was filming a movie
in Santa Fe, and he called me.
And he was like, "Hey, Taylor,
I'm doing, you know,
me and my daughter's
father/daughter trip this year.
I'd love to visit you."
I was like, "Come to Santa Fe.
Like, I'm filming a movie.
Come to set."
So they did.
And it was there that Meghan,
his daughter,
met a buddy of mine, Sandler's
brother-in-law, Chris Titone,
and ever since then,
they've been together.
And Chris wrote this movie
"Home Team" about Meghan's dad.
-What?
-Yeah, so it's a crazy
full-circle story.
-That's crazy full-circle story.
That's awesome.
-Yeah.
-It's super funny.
It's got Kevin James.
It's got you.
And, you know, I saw Schneider,
who's super funny.
Can we set up
what the movie is about?
-Yeah, yeah,
so it's about Sean Payton,
head coach of
the New Orleans Saints.
And the year after
they won the Super Bowl,
he was suspended for a year
from Bountygate.
And it's about what he did
during that year off.
And he ended up moving back
to his small hometown in Texas
and helped coach his 12-year-old
son's Pee Wee football team
and took them to
the state championship game.
-Yeah. It's so --
It's heartwarming.
It's for the whole family.
-All a true story. It's crazy.
-It's a true story.
It's funny.
We were talking backstage.
It's kind of like "Bad News
Bears" but for football.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It's great.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Taylor Lautner
in "Home Team."
Take a look.
-Look, our season hasn't
got off to the best start.
-What are you talking about?
We scored a touchdown.
-We scored a touchdown.
We didn't get shut down.
We scored a touchdown.
-Alright, alright.
True.
But we did still lose 38-6.
-Wow, killing the vibe, Coach.
-Look, I know each of y'all
are doing your best, okay?
We just need something to pull
it all together, a new voice.
-Is Mr. Payton going to be
our new coach?
-Yeah!
-Coach Payton is going to be
our new offensive coordinator.
-Oh, okay.
-How about that?
-Our defense sucks, too.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good line read.
That's a good read.
Taylor Lautner, everybody.
"Home Team" is streaming now
on Netflix.